[Music]
but I'll complete season pass is how
much said have you seen this tell me
about it I mean I'm not bothered about
the costumes or the tracks but playable
Batgirl all right cam what a story cam
anyway have you seen these comments this
has not gone down well but I guess it
wouldn't be the first time that
publishers have given out dodgy season
passes and gamers have been annoyed THQ
promised 40 weeks of DLC for saints row
the third with a season pass offering
money off three big packs that's big in
inverted commas because they were all
rather short averaging about an hour
each in fact three of the four
activities in Genki ball 7 were just
revamped versions of activities from the
main game and although reviewers enjoyed
the final pack the trouble with clones
they questioned why the awesome powers
and items unlocked in the DLC were
unable to be used in the main game the
overwhelming opinion according to fans
was avoid destiny manage to hit a weird
middle ground of being really addictive
despite the ultimately shallow world
unlimited missions on offer a season
pass offered to DLC packs with a meager
$5 saving not owning to Bungie commit
the cardinal sin of having some of the
DLC areas on the disk the dark below
offered an experience that was eerily
similar to what gamers had played before
while the new raid was a hit players
complained that the rest felt recycled
and made previous content meaningless by
allowing players to just buy high spec
items that were better than those that
they'd worked hard for to earn in the
game before the DLC came out titanfall
season pass features three drop pods
they include three new maps each they
originally cost $10 a piece but in
celebration of the game's one-year
anniversary the season pass was made
free for all forever meant as a gesture
of goodwill it's kind of a middle finger
to all of those who stumped up the cache
and finally perhaps afraid that turtle
rocks epic 41 shooter wouldn't recoup
its hefty development costs 2k
implemented a rather convoluted and
expensive
dlc plant that confused rather than
enticed the three pass options the
hunting season pass pc monster race
edition and monster expansion packed all
off at various skins for your monsters
and weapons with the hunting season pass
giving you four new hunters two players
but it didn't impress turtle rock
co-founder fill Rob had to explain that
these items were definitely not shaved
off of the main game to peddle as DLC
but it seems kinda fishy that they
enhanced a whole new monster the
behemoth as DLC before the main game had
even launched he bought everything at
launch evolves DLC would set you back a
hundred and thirty-six dollars that's no
new maps or game modes
that's just cosmetic skins so basically
what I'm saying is games are the worst
yeah it is a good thing that got rid of
online passes but I guess season passes
are probably here to stay
chrisp la comeback
I bet this never happened in Lord of the
Rings I'm listening to a podcast about
serial killers I'm not saying anything
but tell me was Oh think Rizzo thoughts
[Music]